Now that you've seen a couple of exponential functions, let's talk a bit more
in generally about them. We use exponential functions to model relationships in
which a constant change in x creates a proportional change, a percent increase
or a decrease in f of x. In other words, as we saw in our tables that we worked
with, whenever we add a certain amount to x, we're looking at adding one every
time in this case. f of x is going to be multiplied by a certain amount. In the
case of this function, that amount was two. Now the general form of an
exponential function looks like this. f of x equals a to the x power. Here a is
a positive constant other than 1. Before we move on, let's just look at why a
can't be 0 and can't be 1. Well, what is f of x if a equals 0? What if a equals
1? For each of these, rewrite the function as simply as possible.